well my first guest tonight there's a
thing or two about taking down failing
politicians he's one of the most
colorful and controversial people in
American TV news and when he speaks
Millions listen
he's the king of cable news in America
and one of the most influential
conservatives in the world who are these
people do they mean us harm is that
simply a matter of competing for jobs
with American citizens it's potentially
a grave threat for five years and over a
thousand hours of prime time television
Tucker Carlson's been the voice of
American outrage more than three million
people watch him every night on Fox
where he defies consensus defies Elites
and defies censorship it's hard to think
of an ideal more American than the
freedom of speech to the left he's
probably going to be number one a
phrases and ideas that are really core
to the racist white nationalist movement
he wants you to believe the concern
about white supremacy in America is a
hoax which is very convenient for a guy
whose show has been dabbling in it for
years his fans is a straight talking
Superstar asking the questions nobody
dares to ask what is this really about
why do I hate Putin so much has Putin
ever called me a racist tonight for once
he's going to be answering my questions
and it's uncensored
well I've done it to say that Tucker
Carlson joins me now Tucker thank you so
much for joining the show again oh
thanks for having me Pierce I want to
start by I've got Mike Tyson on the show
after you Tucker and Tyson probably the
two most infamous American pugilists
only in very different ways you verbally
him physically you're gonna think
sometimes you're living the life of Mike
Tyson with the the Rough and Tumble of
American cable news
no my my Mike Tyson plays for Keeps I've
always loved Mike Tyson I know I'm a
boxing fan and there were a lot of
people in the boxing world who were
appalled by Mike Tyson because they
thought effectively he was too Savage I
always admired Mike Tyson's boxing
um so but no that's not even I mean I
work in a very gentlemanly low stakes
worlds compared to Mike Tyson you know I
watched your solos as I often do and I
looked for the devil I looked for this
person that your critics scream about
morning noon and night they're
supporting human being I didn't find him
I found somebody engaged in Spirited
opinion uh most of which actually last
night I happen to agree with somebody
who was very courteous to his guests uh
respectful of their opinions listen to
them
um where do you get this reputation from
and do you care
well to answer the second question first
obviously I don't care I wouldn't be
doing it I care what people I love think
of me I care deeply about it I'm
controlled by really to a great extent
by my desire to please the people I love
it's not a huge group of people but I
have a lot of children and and a wife
and friends and staff and I love them
all and so I do care what they think I
do not care what Strangers think I'm not
sure why I should as for you know how
I'm perceived obviously we don't see
ourselves clearly I I know you know this
very well having lived in public life
for many decades
um but from my perspective I'm very
moderate I don't want radical change of
any kind I'm an American I've lived here
all my life
I always think I like 1985 for example
this was a happy prosperous country
people were pretty reasonable they
tolerated disagreement with others they
didn't hate their neighbors because they
voted for someone different and I want
to return to that that's my goal if
that's fascism okay fine but that's
that's what I want I don't want a
revolution at all I'm the opposite of a
revolutionary I'm temperamentally
conservative I want to conserve the good
things about my country and that's how I
feel and I would say also that in
general I'm I can certainly be a jerk I
have been in public many times but in
general I like other people and I have
no interest in being rude I believe in
politeness so I don't see myself as a
radical divisive figure in the slightest
I see myself as kind of a moderate
middle-aged guy in a v-neck sweater
and you sport that sweater very well
tackled if I may say so
I want to turn to the the state of our
two countries really because they're
joined I think in one sense by two
leaders who many people believe have
literally fallen asleep at the wheel I
want to play a little mashup for you
this is of President Biden and our prime
minister for the moment Liz Truss
now what struck me uh Tucker about both
leaders from these clips is a the
extraordinary delusion that they are
somehow doing a brilliant job but
secondly how do we get to a place where
America and the UK two of the great
countries of the world where there is
such a pulsity of talent available in
the political Arena you end up with
these kind of leaders who by Common
consent are at best mediocre and
certainly in the case of our prime
minister right now of just six weeks
completely and utterly useless
that is the obsession of my life how did
great and impressive countries filled
with hundreds of millions of great
impressive people wind up led by the
worst among them and look I mean I think
we should start with the obvious which
is the democracy is not real in the west
the majority doesn't get what it wants
consistently over time obviously that's
how you know leadership makes all the
difference if you have good leaders
you've got prosperous happy stable
countries and if you don't you have the
opposite so leadership really matters
clearly the systems that we've had in
place post-war for the last 80 years to
raise up talent and put it in positions
to rule over the rest of us that system
is very flawed it's producing instead
short-sighted day traders who have no
real investment in the countries they
lead no long-term vision for those
countries and no moral strength they're
weak and weak leadership in the home as
in the nation results in disaster if you
have parents who can't make a decision
you know you have kids who are out of
control and the same is true in Nations
and that's what we're seeing but we need
a total revamp of the system in the UK I
would say in the whole anglosphere I
would add New Zealand Australia Canada
to that list because those are the
countries that have fallen the farthest
the English-speaking world
all those countries need to rethink how
they're raising up leaders because it's
not working no I mean I saw an
extraordinary clip of the weekend to
President Biden munching an ice cream
which is never a good look for a man
actually in public but also what he said
was so extraordinary let's take a look
at it again
well it's predictable I mean it was I
wasn't the only one that thought it was
a mistake
anyway I just think I I disagreed with
the policy but that's up to Great
Britain to make that judgment not me
what I loved about this Tucker was there
was President Biden who is presiding
over a shambolic economy in America
Again by Common consent taking the high
moral ground as if somehow he's some
great economic Guru the British prime
minister is completely clueless well I
don't disagree with him but I don't
think he's a position to say that
frankly given what's going on here but
again he he clearly believes he's
absolutely nailing it when in fact what
he is doing is nailing most People's
Bank balances well I think that's
exactly right you have this weird cycle
and you see it again all over the
English-speaking world you see it in New
Zealand maybe most clearly this idyllic
country with virtually no big problems
run really into the ground by leaders
who not only don't care about the future
of the country they run but are totally
unwilling to acknowledge their failures
it is this kind of syndrome where the
more more exposed they are as
ineffective and incompetent and in some
cases I would say Sinister the more
tightly they cling to the fiction that
everything is great it really is you
know in the old cliche the band on the
deck of the Titanic I mean they're gonna
play their music until they sink beneath
the waves it's this is a disaster like
if you again if you ran your personal
life this way you would have no real
relationships if you made a mistake and
never admitted it and no it's always
your fault you would be
without friends you know no one could
bear to be with you and but that's what
they're like
the big question I think for British
viewers in particular about America
right now is what is going to happen
with Donald Trump what do you think is
going to happen is he going to run again
for president and if he did would that
be a good or bad thing for the Democrats
well I think that the Democratic party
has re-energized Donald Trump and his
voters by sicking the Department of
Justice on him and raiding his home uh
which they did in August and I think
that reminded people that maybe the
thing they like best about Trump is how
much he is hated by the people in charge
that really is his great strength they
hate him
um I don't know if he's going to run or
not I keep hearing that he is and that
he will announce by the end of this year
2022 I I can't confirm that I don't
think however that the people currently
in charge will sit by and allow that to
happen if they can help it I mean I
really think they plan to Hound Trump uh
into dropping out of politics forever
he's not because he's some sort of
threat to the federal bureaucracy no
Trump's threat excuse me is that he's
willing to say what he really thinks
he is uncontrolled and they hate that
that's completely true
um we've got a banner at the moment
saying Tucker Carlson uncensored quite
clearly you've never been censored I'm
not entirely sure I have but we could be
so appears more than I sent it anyway
um on censorship on Free Speech I think
I share your belief it's probably never
been under greater attack than it is
today and in a way the kind of illiberal
Liberals are behaving like the very
fascists they profess to hate and they
want to dictate how we should all be
thinking and what we should all be
saying and the consequences if we don't
sign up to this kind of ultra woke world
view is that you get shame vilified and
canceled but my question for you is not
that because I I think we we agree about
how Insidious this is to society but
where is your line for this and in
particular I'll give an example in in
the news recently of Alex Jones that the
shock jog I've had a few run-ins with
him before
um this whole case of the Sandy Hook uh
families who sued him and got nearly a
billion dollars what did you make of the
that did you feel that he crossed a line
which should not be acceptable even if
you believe passionately in free speech
that if you basically spew lies which I
think he knew to be lies for massive
commercial gain and inflict endless new
misery on grieving families to the
extent they get death threats and so on
did he cross a line
well sure I mean I would never defend it
I mean to the extent I understand what
he said which I don't really but I mean
clearly he said things that wounded that
hurt the feelings of the Sandy Hook
families and that's bad and I would
never defend that I live in a country
where the people with actual power not
Alex Jones but people who run the
Federal Reserve and the federal
government and the Pentagon lie every
single day about things that really
really matter they lied about the Corona
virus for two years and really destroyed
the American economy and killed people
and they were never held to account the
Federal Reserve shaved 30 percent off
the value of the US dollar and nobody
was indicted so like yes I'm against
lying I try not to engage in it myself I
really do try actually
um but people do lie and it's sort of a
hierarchy of of of crime here I mean
like the people who tell the biggest
lies get to remain on television spewing
their self-righteousness and the people
at the margins who criticize them who
get caught lying are silenced so this is
censorship censorship only benefits the
people in power it's always an attack on
the weak always that's what this is
they use the civil code civil lawsuits
to silence people they don't like it's
happened to me thankfully I work for a
big company Fox which has defended me
but if I didn't you know I'd be silenced
and impoverished because they would sue
me for lying and hurting people in words
or violence the truth is words are not
violence violence is violence shooting
people is bad they don't have a problem
with that our murder rate in American
cities has gone up 40 in a year thanks
to their policies they don't care they
don't care about actual violence what
they care about is any threat to their
hegemony to their power and Alex Jones I
guess they thought presented some threat
to that so they crushed him I mean
that's what's really going on and I say
that as someone who does you know I
don't think you should like criticize
the families of children who were
murdered obviously I think that's in
very bad taste but it's not violence
the other person that we're debating
later on the show who has an issue with
the truth and in particular in espousing
truthful statements is Meghan Markle uh
the debate we're going to be having is
whether Americans have had their fill of
the Duchess of Sussex as an American do
you have a view
well I always thought she was ridiculous
and I felt sorry for
the Brits I mean I am you know I guess
by birth partly English I mean my
ancestors came from there and so I don't
I don't follow it super carefully but I
love your literature and I've always
admired your culture and and I and I'm
you know broadly speaking I guess
sympathetic to the continuity that the
real family represents and so from my
perspective as an American I look at
Meghan Markle and I'm like this is a bad
idea why how did you fall for that this
chick's from La she's a failed actress
she's clearly
acting out of bad intent she wants to
destroy things she didn't build and I
just never understood why anyone I mean
I thought she was like a ridiculous
narcissist from the first words I heard
emerged from her mouth like it never
occurred to me to take her seriously and
I and I watched with shock as you got
fired over calling her to account for an
obvious life and then
I watched as one of your friends got
fired for trying to defend you I just
interviewed her the other day the whole
thing was so insane historians will
write about this it was Preposterous uh
Tucker great to have you on the program
thank you very much for taking the time
I really appreciate it thanks for having
me
all the best